Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
All: Who wants to shake it up
with us at The Yard?
Let me have
that sample right there.
Together,
we'll change the world.
Which I'm against.
[ Laughs ]
My mother and I left Vietnam
on a fishing boat.
Greiner: Wow.
We ended up
in a refugee camp.
Immigrants get it done,
right?
[ Laughs ] Yeah.
What's sales
on a good store?
$1,400,000.
What?!
We know that our margins
are slim right now.
O'Leary: That's a structural
problem with this deal.
Every Shark's
not gonna like it.
I mean,
I'll go ahead and do this,
even if I have to
sell my house.
Wow!
This was
just a hobby for us.
Now it's a nightmare.
This is so weird.
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is a shoe company
that seeks to stay on trend
and save you money.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks! Hi, Sharks!
‐Aww!
‐[ Laughs ]
My name is Lisa Nguyen,
and this is my honey,
Duc Nguyen.
This is our daughter Kaia
and her sweet friend Audrey.
We are from Huntington Beach,
California,
and we're here
seeking $100,000
for 15% equity
in our company.
Sharks, if you have kids,
like us,
then you know one of
the biggest challenges
of keeping up
with their wardrobe
is that they are
constantly growing.
You find
that perfect pair of shoes,
they wear it out
once or twice,
and then
just like that...
Boom! Boom! Boom! Boom!
They've already
outgrown them.
So we thought,
"What if we could invent
one shoe that could be styled
with every single outfit
in the wardrobe?"
Sharks,
that's exactly what we did.
Introducing
Baubles + Soles.
Our patent‐pending,
interchangeable shoes
allow your little one
to customize that perfect pair.
Whether it's adorable piggies
for a playdate...
[ Laughter ]
Or pompoms
for that perfect party,
with Baubles + Soles,
one shoe equals
endless possibilities.
Our functional
and fashionable shoes
are machine‐washable,
slip‐resistant,
totally recyclable,
and, best of all, they're made
right here in America.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to go
from playground to party
with us?!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
We have some
stylish samples for you
in which Kaia and Audrey
will help us.
High five.
High five, high five.
Yay!
Give this to him.
Good work, Audrey.
Thank you so much.
Herjavec: Oh, so cute!
So, Duc is actually gonna
show you how to use this.
Duc: You put three fingers
inside as a support.
And with the other hand,
you take the bauble,
align it 90 degrees,
and then twist clockwise.
Sorry.
Greiner: Clockwise.
Clockwise.
Cuban: Ta‐da!
‐Yay!
‐Oh, I see.
Push it down
and then twist anti‐clockwise
to take it out.
Okay. Anti‐clockwise.
Got it.
‐Bye.
‐Bye, guys.
Bye‐bye!
Bye!
‐Bye.
How did you
come up with the idea?
Sure. So, like a lot
of businesses owned by mom,
it was inspired
by my first daughter.
When Kaia
was 10 months old,
she had this pair of shoes
that somebody had given her,
and it had
a red heart on it.
And I knew I didn't want
to buy more shoes
because she was gonna outgrow
that in two to three months.
And so I thought,
"Gosh, I wish I could just
take out that red heart."
So we went on a journey
to make it happen.
We obsessed, studied.
We found a mold maker
to make the shoes for us,
the tooling.
John: And how many
different items do you have
to attach to the shoe?
Yeah, so, right now,
we have about 20.
What does one package cost
for the base shoes?
Duc: It cost us,
with the packaging, about $11.
We sell them retail
for $49.95...
Wow.
...and wholesale, $25.
How much are they
individually,
to buy a package
of the characters?
So, $12.95 to $16.95,
depending what they are.
So, what is your background,
both of you?
So, I was born
in Montreal, Canada.
[ Speaking French ]
[ Laughter ]
So, I came here
when I was 20 years old
to pursue my film degree.
10 years ago,
I founded my company.
What is
your company?
Wedding video production.
Lisa,
what's your background?
My mother and I left Vietnam
on a fishing boat.
We ended up in a refugee camp
for three years.
Wow.
We were one of
the lucky few, you know?
I mean, 25% of people
who did this died at sea.
Then we resettled to Australia,
where I grew up ‐‐
and hence the accent.
Oh, wow.
In Australia,
I got into law school.
I worked in banking and finance
for a short while
and then just realized,
you know,
"Life has to be more
extraordinary than this."
So I gave that all up,
and I went to the Philippines
to volunteer to do
pro bono legal work.
So, we helped refugees
like us.
Wow.
Then was offered,
after a year,
a full‐time job
as the executive director
of a nonprofit.
So I moved
to Washington, D. C.,
and that's how
I came to America.
John:
We've had a lot of people
who went through
tough situations.
I don't think we've ever
heard of somebody...
A refugee. Yeah.
...that went to a refugee camp,
that lived there.
It's an amazing story.
So you know that she's
gonna be a hard worker.
Immigrants get it done,
right?
[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Okay,
what are your sales?
In the last 12 months,
we have made $150,000.
How did you sell that?
So,
we have our website.
A lot of our business
is actually wholesale
and international
distribution.
So, actually, 80% of
our business right now
is to wholesale
overseas.
80% is to wholesale?
Is to wholesale.
This year, we're projected
to do $300,000.
Yeah.
And our predicted profit
is about $170,000.
So, guys,
what are you looking for?
We are looking for
a strategic partner.
We see a huge opportunity
here in America.
John:
So, this is challenging for me
because this is
an inventory challenge
you're gonna have.
You're gonna have
a nightmare with that
because
you have to stock up
on so many sizes,
so many colors,
and then
so many more accessories.
And in my business,
the thing that has killed
more people than the plague
has been inventory.
I really love your story,
but, unfortunately, I'm out.
Oh, Daymond.
So, we actually ‐‐
Herjavec: Lisa, I ‐‐
Sorry. Let ‐‐ Can I ‐‐
Lisa, I really respect
your story.
I think when you come from
those kind of circumstances ‐‐
I mean, you start
from the bottom,
you can only go up.
Um...
Can I just say, we only need
to make 300 pairs per go?
Our hold on inventory
is not ‐‐
Per what?
So, every time
they injection‐mold,
300 pairs minimum.
I have to be
transparent with you.
I don't love it.
I think
it's a cute product,
but what really concerns me is,
in a year,
you've really only sold $30,000
through your website.
You've got to grow
that market, and so...
I'm out, 'cause I think
the market's not talking to me
through those sales.
We've done no advertising.
But maybe the market's talking
to one of the other Sharks.
We've done absolutely
no advertising.
But, Lisa,
that's the challenge, right?
Can I add one more thing
before you ‐‐
Sure.
So, one of the things
that we're doing
to grow
our direct‐to‐consumer ‐‐
and it's something
that we're still
thinking about ‐‐
is the ‐‐ You know
the Build‐A‐Bear model?
We have the capacity
to allow our customer
to build a shoe
on our website.
You're making my point.
O'Leary: Yeah.
So, what you guys have
is a great product,
but it's not
obviously different.
And so because of that,
you have to find
a way to market it.
And you haven't
found that yet.
And so, because you're not
quite sure how to market it,
you're searching for things
that are accelerants.
You want to add
more sizes
because somebody told you
you need more sizes.
You want to copy
potentially Build‐A‐Bear
so that when somebody comes,
they have more alternatives
and maybe that'll get them
to buy the shoes.
You haven't figured out
the way to market it yet.
That's what you have to do,
first and foremost.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
I think that just ‐‐
I would like to say
something here.
You know,
most often in "Shark Tank,"
people like you
come and stand on that carpet
and ask for
ridiculous valuations.
Here, we have a situation
where you've actually come in
with a realistic valuation ‐‐
just over $600,000.
I think you've built
$600,000 worth of value.
We're here for the deal.
And I appreciate that
because ‐‐
We've been offered
other investments,
and we've just said no to them
because this is ‐‐
we're here for you guys.
I mean ‐‐
No, I understand that,
and I appreciate it.
And that's apparent.
That's apparent.
This was a really
remarkable presentation,
I must say,
and a good valuation.
Very good.
So the question
becomes,
"Do I want to be
in the shoe business?"
You know, I've learned
a lot about shoes
on "Shark Tank"
over a decade.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
I just don't want to be
in the shoe business,
not because you haven't done
a spectacular job presenting.
I'm hopeful
that Lori's still here,
and she likes
a lot of plastic stuff.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you,
Mr. Wonderful.
This is
a demonstrable product.
Last month, our returning‐
customer rate was 46%.
So we know that when we get
a customer, they come back.
They come back
for more baubles,
and they come back
for larger sizes.
Greiner: Well, that's
a very good thing for you.
Sitting here today,
you really very much moved me
with your life story.
Often,
the most successful people
have gone through
major hardship.
It gives them
strength and grit
and a bounce‐back and a drive
like no other, and ‐‐
Lori, before you say
what you're gonna say,
the direct‐to‐consumer
market
is an opportunity
for us to grow.
No, I totally get that.
For me, I have to weigh,
"Where do I think
is a right investment?"
at the same time
against my heart.
So, believe me,
my heart with you...
Please.
...was so 100% in,
but I do feel that this is
gonna be a tough journey
because of
the competitive landscape
and because the shoe business
alone is really hard.
But because
we're made domestically,
we do hold on
to very little inventory.
It's ‐‐
And it's not ‐‐
We can turn around that
inventory very, very quickly.
I'm sorry to say
I'm out.
But I will add this.
When this happens,
trust me ‐‐
it's not the end at all.
So, please trust me here.
We're here for you guys.
Can we de‐risk this deal
for you?
Could we de‐risk it?
Can you what?
Can I de‐risk it?
So, for $100,000...
How do you de‐risk it?
...how about if we pay you
that back in two years
from the revenue that we make
from the profits that we make?
I know this company's
going to work,
and I know
that I'm here for a Shark.
This has been
our biggest dream,
and we're here.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks have gone out,
but Lisa is not
giving up easily
in trying to get a deal
for her interchangeable
kids shoe company,
Baubles + Soles.
Could we de‐risk it?
Can you what?
Can I de‐risk it?
So, for $100,000...
How do you de‐risk it?
...how about if we pay you
that back in two years
from the revenue that we make
from the profits that we make?
I know this company's
going to work,
and I know
that I'm here for a Shark.
This has been
our biggest dream,
and we're here.
It's just, the business
isn't at the point
where I feel I can invest in it
to get that level of return.
But I think
you'll figure it out.
I see you're
very emotional about it.
We're here for you.
No.
Greiner:
But let me explain ‐‐
Listen, you're not gonna fail.
You're not gonna fail.
I'll give you $100,000
for 25%.
Wow.
♪♪
I got to be in business
with you. Straight deal.
♪♪
Daymond,
you got a deal.
O'Leary: Whoa!
I got to be in business
with you. You're amazing.
Thank you.
Lori.
You know what?
I'm so glad that he did this.
He's a great partner
for you.
Thank you so much.
O'Leary:
Good luck to you.
Robert, you might as well be
Brad Pitt to me.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Congratulations.
Mr. Wonderful, bye‐bye.
Thank you.
‐Bye.
‐Good job, guys.
Good job, D. J.
Wow.
Oh, my God!
I feel ‐‐
They were all out.
What was
the tipping point?
30‐day turnaround time
on her shoes.
She can go
with low minimums.
But you knew all that
before she said ‐‐
No, I didn't. Sort of, but then
she's just not gonna quit.
She's not gonna stop.
Cuban:
She's not a quitter.
When he went out,
my heart just dropped down
to my tummy and I just ‐‐
I'm so just
incredibly thankful.
And I think that, you know,
"Shark Tank" is an example
that if you work
really hard
and if you refuse
to take any other outcome,
you're gonna be
successful.
We're so excited
to partner with Daymond.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 9,
Robert Herjavec made a deal
with Brent Davidson
and Bryan Cantrell
for their portable campfire,
Radiate.
This product
is gonna be huge.
Let's see how Radiate
is doing now.
♪♪
‐Thanks so much, you guys.
‐Thank you!
‐Hope you have a good time.
‐Take care.
Business has been on fire
since "Shark Tank."
You brought us Radiate,
which I am really excited about.
Cantrell: Within a month,
Robert took us on "The View"
to introduce our product
to a whole new audience.
Why can I not
think of an invention?
Robert was able to introduce us
to major retailers
and even got us in
with Bed Bath & Beyond.
Now we're in more than
1,000 brick‐and‐mortar
retailers worldwide.
Davidson:
All this growth has led
to a huge partnership
with Night Lights events,
a company that specializes
in lantern release festivals
across the U. S.
Alright,
who needs a Radiate?!
I invested in Radiate
'cause I love the guys
and I love the product.
Soon as I saw it, I said,
"This is fun, this is cool,
and we're gonna sell
a lot of them."
Fun and cool, just like me.
Everybody say "Radiate"!
All: Radiate!
When we pitched
the Sharks,
we had only had $16,000
worth of sales.
It's now been 18 months,
and we've sold $2.1 million
in retail sales.
♪♪
Herjavec: Oh, my God.
This is going to be so cool!
It's gonna go.
Oh, wow!
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God,
it makes me want to cry.
Come here, guys!
[ Laughs ]
The thing I love
about "Shark Tank" ‐‐
you don't have to
have experience.
You don't have to have
a big education.
All you got to do
is have the desire
and make a great product.
Bryan and Brent
came on our show.
18 months later, they have
a multimillion‐dollar company.
If that doesn't inspire you,
then nothing does.
Man,
what a great success story.
Thanks for joining us,
man.
Thank you.
Davidson: This event
has been magical ‐‐
over 12,000 people here,
over 1,000 Radiates sold.
"Shark Tank"
makes dreams come true.
This is proof of it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a clothing brand
for fashionable customers.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Scott.
And I'm Gina.
We're a husband‐and‐wife team
from Minneapolis, Minnesota,
and today,
we're seeking $250,000
for 17% equity
in our company.
We've designed
a fresh, fun apparel line
that is,
without a doubt,
the most social‐media‐worthy
clothing brand
on the market today.
Our designs have been worn
by the most famous influencers
on social media,
but they might not be
the movie stars
or TV personalities
that you're thinking of.
♪♪
Herjavec: Awwwwww!
[ Laughter ]
Dog Threads is
a modern apparel brand
with "paw‐sitive"
vibes...
[ Laughter ]
...because
each shirt sold
helps an animal
in need.
And, Sharks...
Best of all...
...best of all...
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
They match.
‐Oh!
‐Oh, my!
We've got a shirt for you
and your favorite pooch, too.
John:
Aww! [ Laughs ]
Dog Threads is available
in matching styles
for the entire family,
whether it's
your dog's birthday,
a holiday greeting‐card photo,
or just a backyard barbecue.
So, Sharks, which one of you
wants to invest in a company
that'll bring a smile
to your face
and make your bank account
happy?
Scott: And, Sharks, we have
some samples for you today
that we'll come
and bring to you.
Let me have that sample
right there.
And if you have a pup,
we'll give those for you,
as well.
O'Leary:
He's a model dog.
Here's a coordinating set
for your twins and Lola.
How you feeling
about your outfit?
Herjavec: Thank you.
Thank you.
Gina:
From our recent line.
Here's our
best‐selling combo.
Appreciate it.
Thanks.
So, tell us about
how you're selling it
and how it's going.
Yeah, so, today,
about 80% of our business
is direct
through our online store.
Online. Yeah.
Herjavec:
Mark, what do you think?
And about 20%
is through retail.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐It looks better on the dog.
Robert,
that looks amazing.
[ Chuckles ]
Enjoy Hawaii.
Moving on...
[ Chuckles ]
So, as I was saying,
about 20% is through retail.
For the most part,
our retail sales
are the dog clothes,
which is about
75% of our business.
And most of
our direct sales
have the matching human clothes
ordered with it.
I love dogs, but...why?
[ Laughs ]
Okay, so, honestly,
it started in 2014.
We had a Pomeranian poodle,
and he loved getting dressed up.
But I couldn't
find clothing
that matched his humanlike
personality anywhere.
Every store I went in,
it was really cheap
and tacky clothing.
And we thought to ourselves,
"I wouldn't wear that,
so why would we dress Thomas
in that?"
Where is Thomas?
Dead?
So ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
I was just asking.
That was a bit harsh,
but...
Thomas, who you can see
here in our pictures ‐‐
he was our ‐‐
Herjavec: Bye. Bye!
‐Bye.
‐[ Laughs ]
He was our ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Thomas was our firstborn child,
if you will.
Yeah.
Unfortunately, he passed away
this last Christmas.
Sorry.
Oh, Kevin!
Scott: And, uh ‐‐
Yeah, Kevin!
He's built a legacy,
and it's living on
through each dog
that wears his designs.
How did it go from
"This is super cute"
to "Honey,
let's make a business"?
So, I went to school
for design.
I was actually designing
my own women's clothing line
at the time,
which is why Scott said,
"Why don't we just
make them ourselves?"
So, I drafted my first
little pattern for Thomas.
It was
a button‐down shirt.
Everywhere we went, people
would come up to us and say,
"Where did you get that?"
But being animal lovers,
we were like,
"There's probably
an opportunity here
for us to make some money
and take some of that
and donate back to animals."
What are your sales?
We've sold almost
a half a million dollars.
Over what period of time?
Since when?
‐A half a million dollars?
‐What?!
Since November 2014,
we've sold $465,000.
Oh.
However, this was
just a hobby for us
until about
a year and a half ago.
We both
had full‐time jobs.
Now it's a nightmare.
And ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
It may be a nightmare for you,
but ask the dog lovers,
and I guarantee that
they're saying this is not.
So, tell us
the last either ‐‐
Well, let's just go
year to date.
Sure. So, year to date, we've
done about $75,000 in sales.
Last year,
we did $196,000 in sales.
Wow.
That's really good.
And this year, we're projecting
to do $240,000 in sales.
So, how much
have you invested?
$500.
That's it?
That's it.
We started small.
We've been focused on profit
since day 1.
We started by making 25,
and we took the profits
from those...
Oh, good for you.
...reinvested.
Why don't more people do that?
That's the only way to do it.
We've been very thoughtful
and deliberate
with how
we've spent the money,
and at this point,
we're saying, "You know what?
We need
a cash infusion."
So, what does it cost? You never
told us what the price of it is.
And what
your cost to goods sold are.
So, our dog shirt,
these classic
button‐down shirts ‐‐
a size small costs $10.75
to make.
We retail it for $40.
Whoa.
Our human matching set
right here ‐‐
this is a best‐seller ‐‐
we make it for $21.50,
and we sell it for $68.
So, who else
is doing clothing ‐‐
matching clothing
between dog and person?
So, there has been
a brand out there
who's done
matching pajamas,
mostly just
for the holiday season,
but this is
a much different product.
These are things you can take
and wear to work.
What about with
licensed merchandise?
I could see Mavs fans,
you know, with the Mavs logo ‐‐
That's a great idea.
Have you guys done
anything similar?
We have not done licensing yet,
but we're 100% open to it.
I actually think
what Mark just said
is a really good thought.
So, I personally think
Mark would be
a fabulous partner for you.
I think that that could
really help accelerate you.
But I think
he's a better partner for that.
So, I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
We appreciate that.
Okay, guys, I don't
think anybody loves animals
more than I do.
I really love them.
I'm on the board
of the Petco Foundation.
But I don't want to see Blake
in my underwear, you know?
Like, I have to be able
to really relate to it,
and I will never, ever
dress like Blake.
[ Laughter ]
This one's tough for me,
but I'm out.
So, guys,
the challenge is your margins,
particularly if
you're gonna try to resale.
So if I brought it into the Mavs
to sell a matching set,
the margins
just aren't there.
Right.
So, how do we
solve that?
So, we're actually looking at
other manufacturers.
We know that our margins
are rather slim right now
because we have to produce
such little at a time
due to lack of funds.
Would you do T‐shirts,
though?
Absolutely
we can do T‐shirts.
Of course.
Absolutely.
I smell an offer
coming from Mark.
Let me tell you
where I'm at.
I can't get my head around
dressing up a dog.
I just can't get there.
I'm not saying there isn't
a market or people won't do it.
It's just, I can't do it.
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay, guys,
I'll make you an offer.
I'm kind of on the fence,
but I like what you're doing.
I'll give you the 250K,
but I want 30%, right?
Because that'll give me
a reason to invest.
I'll connect you
with our Mavs buyers,
the licensing
for the NBA.
There's a lot we can do
in terms of pricing.
The Mavs buy,
I can't even tell you,
how many hundreds
of thousands of shirts.
I will make you an offer, too,
and I'll tell you why.
I have learned ‐‐
I'm not necessarily gonna
keep my offer there.
Thank you
for your offer.
Is it okay
if we hear Kevin's offer?
No.
I think you should listen
to Kevin's offer...
You know his offers
are always ridiculous.
...'cause I have something
he'll never have.
Your call.
What I've learned
is that ‐‐
Don't do it to yourself,
guys.
No, no.
I'm just saying ‐‐
Mark, can we counter?
Do you want
to hear the offer or not?
Can we counter your offer,
Mark?
Sure.
What we'd like to do
is counter ‐‐
the same $250,000,
but we'd like to do it
for 25%.
It's really important to us
that we maintain enough equity
to make sure we are set
for our family.
We have a 1‐year‐old
at home,
and you guys know the costs
that come with babies.
It is his 1st birthday
today.
Aww!
Gina: He just had to
throw that out there.
And we are somewhat devastated
that we're here
only because
we're missing that.
You're using the baby angle.
Using the baby
to shame me!
Only 'cause
it's his birthday.
‐No, no, no, no.
‐To shame me!
But it's important
that we're building
for his future.
What's the baby's name?
Ziggy.
Let me throw the offer in.
Do all three of you all
dress the same?
All the time. Look at us.
We're right there.
‐Oh, is that ‐‐
‐That's Ziggy right there.
‐Aww!
‐Your baby is so miserable.
Alright,
I'll do it for 25%.
[ Laughing ] Mark!
Thank you so much, Mark.
You've got a deal.
My pleasure.
Awesome.
Congratulations.
Don't you want to know
what the offer was?
Mr. Wonderful,
we still love you.
Of course you do!
Thank you for your time.
Happy birthday, Ziggy.
‐Congrats.
‐Congrats, guys.
Gina: Thank you, Ziggy,
for saving us 5%
with Mark Cuban.
That's going directly
into your college fund
or whatever business
you want to start.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an entrepreneur
who has solved
a familiar problem.
♪♪
It happened so fast.
One moment,
I was the family breadwinner.
The next, I was unemployed
and had to start over.
But I didn't get mad.
Instead, I got hungry.
[ Chuckles ]
So I went home,
and I made a sandwich!
And that's when I knew
I could change the world ‐‐
the world of peanut butter.
My name is Andy Scherer.
I'm asking $200,000
for 15% of the company.
Sharks, peanut butter inspired
me to become an inventor.
It's delicious,
it's nutritious,
and one bite of that sandwich
took me back to my days
as a kid in school.
A lot has changed since then,
but peanut butter
hasn't changed at all.
It's just as hard
to get out of the jar
and just as messy
when you do.
I decided it was high time
to take peanut butter
into the modern age.
So I created
the Peanut Butter Pump.
It makes peanut butter
better.
[ Chuckles ]
Now get ready,
because for the first time
in history on national TV,
we're going to download
a sandwich.
♪♪
‐Ooh!
‐Oh, wow.
Ooh!
Scherer: Ahh!
Herjavec: Ahh!
Voilà.
One downloaded sandwich.
That's cool.
Now anyone
can make a sandwich
or a healthy snack
quicker, cleaner,
and easier than ever before.
You can easily measure it
for your favorite cookie recipe.
And look how it cleans
the sides of the jar
so you don't have to.
I designed it to get
every last bit of peanut butter
from the jar.
People love this pump.
It's truly a game changer.
Together,
we'll change the world ‐‐
the world of peanut butter.
♪♪
There's good news here.
I am a peanut butter
connoisseur.
[ Laughs ]
Wonderful.
And in my home,
I buy artisan peanut butters.
Okay.
I've been known to make
my own peanut butter.
I got
a lot of questions.
Okay.
Number one, when you get
to the artisan peanut butters,
there's a lot of debate
about how much chunk
you have
in the crunch factor.
Oh, my God.
How big
will you let the chunks be
before it clogs up
the pump?
Right now, the inlet
has a 10‐millimeter.
Alright,
I'll give you that.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, within the
peanut butter community,
there's a raging debate
over refrigeration
after it's open, okay?
Do I put that giant stack
in the refrigerator?
No.
Do you keep peanut butter
in the refrigerator?
Oh, yeah.
Many, many ‐‐
You're not supposed to.
It's a huge debate
in the ‐‐
I don't think
you're supposed to.
In the community, you ‐‐
No.
'Cause it gets too hard.
No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Within the peanut butter
community, there's
a massive debate
because the oils separate
at room temperature.
Now, where do you
find this community?
Go online.
Do you have a sample of it
that's not in the jar?
Well, that's what
the poster is here for.
Greiner:
Oh, it's a prototype.
‐This is a prototype?
‐Oh, there's no sales yet.
There are sales.
I have plenty of pre‐orders,
but let me tell you ‐‐
these are prototypes.
Pre‐orders.
John: Okay.
And it only works
for stabilized peanut butter.
Tell us about your history,
how you came up with the idea.
I was laid off from a job
in financial services.
You worked at a bank?
Currency exchange.
When I was laid off, I decided
to become an inventor.
How long ago was that?
That was 2 1/2 years ago.
And then the Peanut Butter Pump
was born.
And then
the crowdfunding campaign...
Tell us about that.
How much did you ask for?
The initial ask
was $20,000,
and the total sales now
are $129,000.
There is a community,
Kevin!
How much does it cost?
What do you sell it for?
The average price
on the campaign was $27.
Is that a lot?
It's a lot.
O'Leary: Let's focus on
the task at hand.
The truth is,
30% want chunky.
It's a raging debate
in the community.
Everybody knows that.
He just likes saying
"chunky."
So, I have to buy two pumps
to have both available,
and you won't let me
refrigerate it
to offset the rancidness.
Kevin, who is the leader
of the peanut butter community?
The community has
two debates, alright?
No,
but who's the leader?
I am the leader.
Why do you know
so much about this?
It only works
for stabilized,
so for people
who are interested ‐‐
‐What's stabilized?
‐That means preservatives.
Which includes extra wax,
which I'm against
'cause it taints
the pureness,
the virginal aspect
of artisan peanut butter.
We don't care, Kevin.
Did you get
kicked out of the community?
Kevin, we don't care.
So, Mr. Andy,
for Peanut Butter Pump,
when are you telling
your Kickstarter contributors
that you will deliver?
Scherer:
Within the coming months.
I've already passed
the initial promise date.
But I've been up front and
transparent about the process.
But you need money
to make them, I'm guessing.
I do. I need money.
So you took in the money
and you already spent it?
I haven't spent
all the money.
However, I have withdrawn
a little bit of money,
and I'm ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
That's not really
what it's for.
But, I mean,
I'll go ahead and do this
even if I have to
sell my house.
Ooh! Ooh! Ooh!
I mean, I'm going to
make good on it.
That's really the whole point.
You have to.
Ooh! Ooh!
I got a question.
Please, Daymond.
[ Laughing ]
"Please, Daymond."
What problem
is it actually solving?
It's really
the classic last mile,
but for peanut butter.
I mean, you have to
take it out of the jar,
you have to scoop it,
you have to scrape
the sides of the jar.
I mean, some people get ‐‐
Andy, listen, I'm out.
[ Laughing ]
I'm sorry.
Daymond, however,
you know,
30 days,
$100,000 in sales.
In 30 days,
you did $100,000 in sales.
That's correct.
If you use peanut butter
once a month,
you're not
going to need a pump.
Isn't this better used
in a commercial ‐‐
'cause how do the commercial ‐‐
how do hotels,
whatever the case is ‐‐
how do they buy?
They probably buy
in huge tubs, right?
This is for high‐volume users,
so families with children...
Kevin.
...with school‐age children.
That's probably about
14‐, 15 million households.
Juice bars ‐‐ every fitness bar
has a juice bar.
I don't think anybody
really needs a pump
to get their peanut butter
out of a jar.
[ Laughing ] And so ‐‐
I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
Well, I don't think
anybody needs a pump
to get hand lotion out,
either, and yet ‐‐
I think it's different, Andy.
I think this is very ‐‐
I think this is
a very elegant design
that you've come up with
for a problem
that I'm not sure it exists,
so ‐‐ I'm sorry ‐‐
I'm out.
♪♪
So, Andy, let's disclose
to the community now,
'cause they're watching.
You are not supporting
the 40% of the community
that wants to refrigerate
after opening.
You know they want refrigeration
after opening...
[ Laughing ]
This is so weird.
...because it...
You can't put it
in a fridge.
...creates a viscosity
that you're not supporting.
It creates a ‐‐
Kevin, Kevin,
I am so sick and tir‐‐
Yes or no, true or false?
Disclose now, Andy.
Kevin, I am so sick of
your peanut butter arrogance.
Mark,
this is very important.
Are you ever going to solve
for the viscosity created
by refrigerated peanut?
I have told people not to put it
in the refrigerator.
The real basic problem is,
$200,000 for 15% is crazy.
There's no bigger advocate
for the commodity than I am,
but this price is nuts.
Like, $200,000 for 15%?
The whole business isn't worth
$200,000 right now.
I wish you the best of luck,
but I'm out.
♪♪
Andy, you're being
a great sport, right?
We're having a little bit
of fun at your expense,
and you're going with it.
Everything's factual, Mark.
Don't insult the community.
Anyways,
from an investment standpoint,
it's just not a fit for me,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Good luck, Andy.
‐Good luck.
♪♪
Scherer: This is not the end
of the Peanut Butter Pump.
People love it,
and it will be made.
I think the Sharks are
a little bit out of touch,
and that's all there is to it.
It's a shame
that they didn't go for it,
but somebody will.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an even more decadent version
of a sweet treat.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Chelsea.
And I'm Logan.
And I'm Ali.
And we're seeking $400,000
for 10% of our company.
Sharks, close your eyes
and imagine
you are 7 years old again
and dreaming
of a magical place.
Are you swimming
with the mermaids?
Are you riding
a unicorn?
Are you eating
a giant jar of ice cream?
Now open your eyes.
It's ice cream?
We made that magical place
come to life.
Introducing
The Yard Milkshake Bar.
Wow.
We're what ice cream dreams
are made of.
We have unicorns.
We have mermaids.
We have edible cookie dough,
sprinkles, and more.
We knew people would love
our milkshakes,
but we did not expect people
to line around the building
to wait for one.
Our picture‐worthy milkshakes
with a Southern charm
had our new customers
coming back day after day.
Logan: So, Sharks...
All: Who wants to shake it up
with us at The Yard?
‐Shake it up.
‐Alright.
Chelsea: We have some samples
for everyone.
And, Mark, I'm gonna invite you
to design your own.
Oy.
I'm afraid already.
Mark's lactose‐intolerant,
so he'll be ‐‐
Yeah, so just don't stand
behind me.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone is
going to get a milkshake.
Ahh! What do we got?
What do we got?
So, we picked
an ice cream for you.
Cool.
But first, we're gonna
decorate your jar.
Everybody gets to take
the jar home with them
once they buy it.
And the first thing we choose
is your icing.
So, we have chocolate icing,
vanilla icing, peanut butter.
Chocolate.
Chocolate for sure?
Everybody gets to either
choose to build their own ‐‐
our menus allow you
to choose what you want ‐‐
or you can choose from one of
our pre‐designed milkshakes.
So, someone's standing
behind the bar.
So, I'm walking through
kind of like a yogurt store
where you pick and choose
or do I do it myself?
We have menus that you actually
fill out yourself.
Wait.
What are these, again?
Those are peanuts.
We can put some on top
for you, if you'd like.
No, let's get
some of the chips.
Yeah, a little bit
of everything.
Okay.
We can definitely put
all that on top for you.
Yeah, put it all on!
If you're gonna go,
go hard.
No calories there,
kiddies.
Chelsea: Chocolate drizzle
on the inside.
Chocolate drizzle
on the inside!
Oh, you are going
to SoulCycle later.
I can already see it.
Robert, this is
our Old School Banana Split.
‐Holy smokes.
‐Wow.
You get to choose one of these
large toppings to go on.
Oh, I'll go with the brownie
since we're doing chocolate.
Perfect choice.
[ Laughs ]
Alright,
and this is yours.
Oh, my gosh.
That looks amazing.
Herjavec: Looks so good.
Should we wait?
‐No. Hell no.
‐You can go ahead.
Hell no.
Logan: Kevin.
Is that a brownie
on top?
A blondie.
Wow!
That's crazy.
Kevin, you have
a hazelnut ice cream.
It's dark chocolate
with hazelnut inside of it.
‐It's good.
‐Oh, my ‐‐ Lori, look at this.
Chelsea: And then for Daymond ‐‐
for you, we have a mint.
Greiner: Honestly,
your chocolate is great.
Herjavec: It's so thick.
Wow.
That's really good.
Yeah.
So rich.
Really good.
Oh, it's so good!
How many calories
does this have in it?
Don't tell me!
Chelsea: Ours range from
650 calories to our most ‐‐
our highest‐calorie one
is 1,800 calories.
‐1,800.
‐1,800?!
Alone. [ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Why is it
called The Yard?
The milkshakes bring
all the boys to the yard.
Yeah, Chelsea,
great call.
[ Laughter ]
What does
a milkshake cost,
and what does it cost you
to make?
The milkshakes retail
for $14 to $20,
depending on
which one ‐‐
$14 to $20?
It's a great price, though,
for that.
We do have a larger size,
and the Shake Boss you see
there, the big one ‐‐ it's $50.
‐Wow.
‐$50?
‐Average ticket item's $25.
Greiner: And what does it cost
to make one?
$4 to $9,
depending on the size.
Why'd you come up with
this idea? What's your history?
And, you know ‐‐
My first ice cream shop,
I started with my mom
in 2010,
and then in 2017,
when we opened The Yard,
we had an opportunity
to go into a spot
who had multiple failed
ice cream shops in it before.
So we knew we had to come up
with something really exciting,
like, really extravagant
to get people coming in.
Chelsea,
what town are you in?
Gulf Shores, Alabama,
was our first location.
What is your history?
Because ‐‐
Logan: My father owned an
electrical contracting company.
We started from scratch.
He worked us
like any dad works you.
Learned the ethic
from him, for sure.
And Ali's story
is what?
Ali,
what's your background?
We're married,
and this is our sister‐in‐law.
This is chief of operations
Ali Rose Green.
Ali is my sister‐in‐law,
and she decided
to come work for us
when we opened The Yard,
just lines out the door.
We couldn't keep up
with the demand.
You said "multiple units."
Where are your other units?
Yeah, 'cause you started
to grow, you said, right?
Yes.
Well, we have
went into franchising now.
So, our first location
was Gulf Shores in 2017, May.
Our second location
was in Panama City Beach,
which is about
three hours away,
and that was the following year,
in 2018.
We also opened a store
in Fairhope, Alabama.
We also have a store
in Austin, Texas.
Walk me through
the franchise deal.
What do I pay you?
So, the franchise license is
$45,000 for a 10‐year license.
We take a 6% continuing royalty
of net sales.
We also take a 2% royalty
for national marketing.
‐So the total royalty's 8%?
‐Yes.
What are the margins
on your best store ‐‐
for you,
the corporate store?
25% to 28%.
Yes. Thank you.
Wow, that's really good.
Yeah, it's excellent.
What's sales
on a good store?
$1,400,000.
‐Wow!
How many
square feet?
We started out
in 1,000 square feet.
What's that store,
the one that's doing 1.4?
How many square feet?
That's the same store.
We upgraded it last year
to 3,500 square feet.
All the extra space
is seating for the customers?
Yes.
Oh, it's a sit‐down restaurant.
Are they all sit‐down?
No.
It's a milkshake bar.
It is.
So, they'll come in.
We have a menu.
They'll fill out the menu.
They check the items
they like,
and then they give it
to our assembly team,
and we have
specialized decorators.
So this is like Chipotle.
Correct, yes. It's ice cream
any way you can think of it.
But why is it so big ‐‐
3,500 square feet?
Well, Gulf Shores
is a seasonal town,
so we have to have
that square footage
to pack as much volume
in there
during that busy season
as possible.
If I'm a potential buyer,
what does it cost me to open,
start to finish?
Anywhere from $140,000
to, say, $315,000.
And how many square feet
do I have to open ‐‐
No. Okay, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Including the license fee.
So, we have
a lease agreement, almost,
with our ice cream
supplier ‐‐
display cases,
freezer equipment,
display refrigeration units ‐‐
it's all free
to my franchisees.
So, if I want
to open one up ‐‐
As long as
we buy their product,
they get all of
their equipment for free.
So, how many do you have
in total?
We personally have four
that we own,
and we have one franchise open
and one franchise sold.
Does this deal include
the stores that you own
or just the franchise part
of it?
We're hoping for right now
to just include the franchise.
Logan, I'm not getting
the stores
that are already working?
That was not
our initial intention.
This story just became
really bad all of a sudden.
Yeah, it did.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they're concerned
that the deal only includes
the franchise part
of the milkshake‐bar business,
The Yard,
and not the corporate stores
with proven sales.
Logan, I'm not getting
the stores
that are already working?
That was not
our initial intention.
This story just became
really bad all of a sudden.
Yeah, it did.
I don't get it. I mean,
that's a structural
problem with this deal.
Every Shark's not gonna like it.
I can tell you right now.
We've seen this structure
before. We don't like it.
We want to wet our beak
in all the ice cream.
Such bad people.
Are you willing to change
the structure of your deal
to continue the dialogue?
I think it's up for discussion,
for sure.
What is the whole business
making pre‐taxes?
Net sales ‐‐ lifetime sales,
$6,400,000.
No, not lifetime ‐‐
this calendar year.
$3,400,000.
Wow.
That's all the stores?
Okay.
And what are you gonna make
on that after everybody's
paid and everything?
It should be roughly
$400,000.
$400,000?
Ooh,
that's a real business.
It's a very, very good
business.
Why do you need more money
right now?
'Cause you're already on
a hockey‐stick,
you know, projection.
You're already
killing it.
Yeah, so, we can definitely
do this on our own,
but I think with one
or multiple of you guys,
we can save a decade.
Herjavec: Walk me through
a little bit.
When I buy a franchise,
how much help do you give me
with finding a location,
designing the physical space?
99% of all of that.
I have
an architectural team
that can consult with them
if they need to.
I've heard enough.
I'll start.
I'll make you an offer.
Okay.
I'll do the $400,000
for 15%.
Now, Kevin, are you buying
just the franchise?
I'm not interested
in just franchise.
I talked about that
in the beginning.
The whole milkshake.
Yeah,
the whole milkshake.
That's what brings them
to the yard.
That's right.
[ Laughter ]
John: Listen, you know, I have
a strategic relationship
and interest in rolling out
the Sugar Factory's products
to traditional
grocery stores,
so this would be competitive
to that aspect,
so, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Greiner:
Well, I love it.
I mean,
I really love it.
I think your marketing's
really smart.
I think
the product's fantastic.
So, I'll offer you
the $400,000.
It would be
for the inclusive,
because when I'm in,
I want to really be all‐in.
We understand.
And I will do it
for 12.5%.
Thank you for the offer.
Cuban: I'm gonna make you
an offer, too.
Okay.
I'm fine with you guys
owning those four stores.
♪♪
I want you guys to use
the $400,000
to open up units,
and I want 25% ‐‐
not of the existing units,
but of the new business.
Okay.
♪♪
Would you do 20%?
22%.
♪♪
Okay. Deal.
Let's do it. Deal.
Deal.
Let's eat!
[ Laughter ]
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
‐Hey, congratulations.
‐Thank you, buddy.
‐Thank you.
‐Good job.
Thank you.
I love how you just totally
ignored Kevin and Lori.
I love that.
[ Laughter ]
Good luck. Congrats.
We'll be talking soon.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Alright!
[ Laughter ]
Logan:
We went with Mark today
because he shares
the same vision as us.
We wanted
to maintain our stores,
and he's just the right guy.
He knows Texas.
He knows Dallas.
He knows the areas
we really want to go to,
and I really think
he's the right guy.
♪♪